[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous d'être là au bon moment
soyez les bienvenus pour garder quatre
premières votre magazine quotidien
consacré au tour de la martinique des
yoles rondes
cela va faire une semaine william que
nous sommes ensemble au coeur de cette
fête unique au monde
quel plaisir de vous retrouver la 7e
étape est partie des anses d'arlet pour
arriver ici à fort de france
au programme de votre magazine les
résultats l'ambiance toujours aussi
chaude et les analyses de notre
spécialiste exactement williams chers
amis nous sommes partis pour 30 minutes
de pur bonheur et on commence tout de
suite avec le résumé de la course du
jour ces coûts cela des embarcations
bord à bord des stratégies opposées des
manoeuvres improbable en pleine mer ou
sur terre
des avaries multiples ceux qui pensaient
le ton enjoué en dû se rendre à
l'évidence les équipages ont fait preuve
d'un engagement exceptionnel sur cette
avant dernière étape
[Musique]
un parcours entre des anses d'arlet et
fort de france passage obligé entre les
bouées sortie espace sud puis arrivée en
baie de fort-de-france avec trois bouées
à virer dernière marque de parcours au
large de chercheurs avant de couper la
ligne d'arrivée à la française départ
tranquille pour les embarcations mais ça
ne va pas durer
observez la différence de voix nue entre
huy fr chantant la moins voilées et
brasserie lorraine car à la vue voilée
des 2 12 m² de différence déterminant
pour le reste de la course
en attendant les franciscains 2 appétit
l'appaloosa ont pris la direction des
opérations
ils ont à coeur de montrer que leur
unique victoire d'étape n'était pas un
concours de circonstances mais sans
information le canot suivant le tour est
difficile pour les frères masse au
chapitre des avaries cette aide et mdf
et diaby scandent cool et c'est loin
d'être fini
devant bagarre pour la deuxième place
brasserie lorraine sarah menace rosette
orange mais la yole franciscaine est
stable l'alluré bonne aco est confiant
d'ailleurs c'est une autre gueule
franciscaine qui va en faire les frais
le dernier jugement
l'armé fatale est beaucoup plus 3 les
pourtant les frères masse résister
résister résister encore jusqu'à des
salles et derrière de stratégie de
course dessine entre félix mérine en bas
de l'écran et diani rémy plus près de la
côte
intercalé entre les deux la voile rose
et jaune de semaine une stratégie
payante bon brasserie légèrement en tête
16 minutes séparent les deux mapipi au
classement général mais l'équipage
marinois s'est montré trop ambitieux les
douze mètres carrés de voile de plus que
leurs concurrents sans trop lourd à
porter après 1h20 de course
les coursiers abdique contre toute
attente il rentre à terre changer de
voile pour le plus grand bonheur des
vacanciers de cette tel du sud une
opération réglé au millimètre l'équipage
est entraîné quatre minutes tout de même
pour repartir
devant le champ est libre pour rosette
orange et ufr chanflor malgré sa
position confortable félix mérine joue
la gagne est attaque son adversaire
alors que plus de deux heures les
séparent au classement général un mental
de compétiteur un remporté neuf fois le
tour ça ne se vend pas à bord de l' arme
fatale on se prépare aux terribles
affrontements
[Musique]
les deux hommes s'observent personne ne
veut se laisser surprendre plusieurs
bords sont attirés en baie de
fort-de-france et des conditions se
durcissent
pour preuve en pleine mer brasserie
lorraine change une nouvelle fois de
voile et accentue son retard
à la dernière boule rosette/orange april
avantage après trois heures de course
les hommes restent concentrés sur une
affaire en revanche on se laisse
surprendre caracoli embarque de l'eau et
suit des rafales et perd du temps
rien ne semble pouvoir arrêter aco
pourtant l'homme surveille ses arrières
avec raison dans le sillage de larmes
fatale caracoli est toujours là une
arrivée au sprint au milieu des
plaisanciers qui voit finalement la
victoire de rosette orange devant ufr
chanflor et son marek petit navire
rosette orange s'impose à fort de france
maigre consolation pour les supporters
après un tour catastrophique du tenant
du titre
ufr champions qui rate un bord sur la
ligne d'arrivée et finalement à une
minute et 34 secondes se marient petit
navire est troisième à 12 ans 4e à 15
minutes
ce même qui a coulé est 6e
[Musique]
la mauvaise opération du jour est signée
brasserie lorraine après avoir changé
deux fois deux voies la course
l'équipage termine à la 11e place
les appétits l'appaloosa et 13e c'était
dm 16e rien ne semble pouvoir enlever la
victoire finale au maillot rouge ufr
chanflor l'écart se creuse avec
brasserie lorraine à 46 minutes
l'enjeu pour la troisième place
demeurent seuls 13 minutes séparent
saumarez petit navire 3e et ait souvent
quatrième établissement rosette orange
est 5e
gf à caraïbes 6e ce même 7e
c'était des mdf est 11e zita 12e
mutuelle mare gaillard 13e tania
chaussures ferme la marche à plus de
onze heures du leader
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
victoire de rosé doublé c'est la folie
je pensais qu'un tueur
c'est la chance de croiser ici roger a
donné l'état mais eu affaire reste
leader en élidé notre deuxième étape
aujourd'hui tu aimes tu sais pas s'ils
n'y en a plus y en a ne rejoint pas
rejoint watkins est toujours vivant
aussi les épines ou gentil merci merci
toro non merci
[Musique]
ce gars je suis pris dans la vague du fr
je suis emporté
[Applaudissements]
ils septième étape de toute beauté
tillard en minable il a fallu presque
une photo finish pour départager ufr
chanflor et rosette orange alors cet
état pour a fait des heureux évidemment
mais aussi des déçus c'est normal on
arrive à la fin du tour à la fin de la
compétition parole aux coursiers pour
savoir comment ils ont vécu de
l'intérieur
ces paroles mapipi avec la soie 7 pouces
avec un au départ on allait partir jouer
et puis il fallait jouer dans la baie de
fois de face mais c'est vrai le vent sa
force un tout petit peu on avait du mal
et sur la fin on a mis tous les poils ou
à bon et je le félicite maison parce que
je pense que c'est grâce à u c'est grâce
à eux si on est arrivé là parce que
c'était dur c'était dit aujourd'hui très
physique
c'était difficile très difficile parce
qu'il y avait du vent y avait dû voir
qu'elles vont maintenant tenter d'aller
mater on avait brassé a été changée
savoir comme jaguar si l'honneur et on a
tous moi mais non plus les deux radios
et on n'est pas en confiance mais je les
ai de confiance et bisons et son côté
aval jusqu'à mon enfance en quoi ça va
de soi place mondiale des marques que
c'est beaucoup dit pas sur nous avant
passante des applications
katia d'espoir il faut se respecter
mutuellement 10 à démarquer c'est en
province comme à certains moments un peu
décalé je veux dire à la révocation
occasion félicitations le gâble ces
temps parce qu'ils ont beaucoup de
rouages et je m'attends à jouer comme on
dit quoi ça depuis dimanche c'est le
buzz aujourd'hui on avait une bonne
surface de voile amusant un peu pensé
combien compte certes mètres carrés on a
souffert du début jusqu'à la fin
bonjour quatrième le soufflé mon temps
je félicite les hommes aussi parce que
les intervalles et il a dit aujourd'hui
bon ça arrive tard mais bon vous ne
saurez jamais bon je vous dis ça fait
plaisir ça mais le match à l'heure au
beau fixe et doit nous permettre en co2
devrait attaquer parce qu'on a déplacé à
prendre des places à prendre
et voilà et nous sommes fiers ce jour
nous sommes jeunes nous sommes fouet aux
dires des voisins mais si je veux
[Musique]
l'un des éléments essentiels pour la
réussite du tour c'est le podium c'est
vrai tout se fasse aucun du podium déjà
pitre performer devant un super public
et pour les animateurs c'est l'occasion
de jouer avec les supporters ils vous
permettent de patienter en attendant les
yoles ambiance à mary lou
la ville capitale à four le français sur
le podium de l'avant dernière étape du
tour de la martinique des yoles rondes
sur la merde
ben c'est un jour très très très beau tv
sur le bonheur aussi ses eaux
mouvementées dans mon fait des gros coup
dur de temps de chants on a des artistes
qui viennent
on a encore des cadeaux que l'on donne
on s'en moque de toi alors 6e podium
juste avant la remise des maillots et
nous amuser my opinion très longtemps on
est là pour lui à patienter pour donner
mon trait sur tout le savoir faire des
artistes martiniquais et partenaires et
tous ceux qui ont quelque chose à dire
ou à tuer des gens
on connaît ce mot aussi jeté à des
personnes qui me disent oui n'était pas
quel podium ça fait toujours plaisir
la reconnaissance on se dit que même si
la musique n'est pas facile et on
dépense beaucoup on a quand même alors
autour d'eux
[Musique]
ça mange à vous lever bon flux pointe
serveurs je la maintiens c'est une
manifestation qui est une dimension
tripartite à la fois culturelles
patrimoniales et sociale et donc en tant
qu'homme martiniquais pour moi il c'est
un devoir que de venir voir une étape de
tourner
[Musique]
c'est pour moi une vitrine
exceptionnelle de pouvoir chanter au
niveau des yoles au niveau des
différents podiums et ses manières pour
moi de vraiment faire connaître ce que
je fait d'avoir autour du public
apparemment ça a l'air de plaire ce qui
me fait très plaisir parce qu'on s'est
mis en ménage travail
simone d'énergie un maximum de bonnes
vibes après c'est toujours un plaisir
d'être sur le podium de la musique et
puis on voit que c'est un type effectif
aussi en même temps donc on est allé
voir la production sous l'eau on voie
légale ce badge et de cuisson sur terre
c'est fini pour ensemble on parle et ça
va rigoler c'est exactement ceci
d'esprit martinique j'avais l'air super
heureux je le vois clair que la nuit
elle voudrait
chaque jour dans quatre premières grâce
à nos caméras embarquées à bord d'une
yole vous découvrez comment s'est
déroulée l'étape de la veille
hier nous étions au coeur de l'équipage
de brasserie lorraine sahara le patron
c'est gianni rémy et à son bord il ya
une des légendes du monde de laguiole
georges-henri lagery l'étape était très
importante pour eux voyons comment ils
ont géré la nano l'image c'est en trio
la faune la flore sont du large et
puisque on sait qu'ils avaient au four
niveau 3 et vient on a bouffé votre
venue en retrait au dessus ça puisqu'on
a eu
la dimension on a on n'a pas roulé polar
est mort cela la vraie option que la
nature sans les payer donc pour nous ça
nous a quand même arrangé
voici pourquoi l'adoption avoir la
preuve soutient hausse a aussi payé
boulot puisque les cèdres ajouté en
cherchant le vent et le vent l'a trouvé
en fait pas au cou n'évolue jamais
[Musique]
l'écurie honda déséquilibre puisse pas
les votes du bateau je sais pas c'est
pas évident et dans la vie dans la rolls
des bateaux discutera des reçoit des
veuves de de tous les sens après une
fois qu'on s'endort dans les vagues des
bateaux là se stabilise ce qu'on a
toujours la même cohésion au niveau de
l'équipage s'est invitée à la route du
bateau ont fait plus de viviez la
vacation bouge plus on sait que des fois
aux loges que qu'il ya du coup une fois
le coach l embarcation
[Musique]
on a fait aussi au niveau du choix le
voilà parti pour météo enfin on pense à
l'avancé à les soulager
mais bon comme on dit le tout n'est pas
terminé
donc on va continuer à se battre pour la
sellette
[Musique]
y a des pattes c'est pas n'importe
quelle classe ce sont des sorbets maison
ronald corey hart cacahuètes
bonjour madame royal
c'est vrai qu'en du voyage alors nos
vélos du coup je prendrais cacahuètes
yvinec moi je prends le coco s'il vous
plaît madame
et bonne à glace est très bonne c'est
une vraie madeleine de proust pour moi
parce que qui sait dans les familles
martiniquaises
il y avait souvent une sorbetière et le
week-end une sorte de tirs en boîte
c'est avec une manivelle manuel et le
week-end les enfants se relayaient pour
tourner la sorbetière tu vois effet
reprendre le sorbet c'était un bon
moment
c'est un joli souvenir aujourd'hui
évidemment les servettiens sont presque
tout automatiser bateaux électriques
elles sont électriques ce qui nous amène
à parler de ce qui est un petit peu de
technique dans notre rubrique technique
yole aujourd'hui on va parler de
laguiole et notamment de la fabrication
de laguiole technique yonne
[Musique]
la coop de laguiole est en bois massif
la taille maximum autorisée est de 10
mètres 50
laguiole pèse environ 800 kilos
laguiole est façonnée par des
charpentiers de marine sans l'aide de
plans uniquement à l'instinct et selon
un savoir faire ancestral les yoles qui
ont réalisé le premier tour en 1966
afficher une longueur variant entre 6
mètres 50 et 7 mètres 50
[Musique]
aujourd'hui la longueur maximale
autorisée est de 10 mètres 50 pour une
largeur allant jusqu'à 2 mètres 50
le profil des yoles varie selon les
équipages qui recherche toujours la
forme la plus hydrodynamique c'est à
dire la coque qui assurera la meilleure
glisse laguiole a une durée de vie de 3
à 10 ans selon les moyens de l'équipage
car elle peut coûter jusqu'à vannes 5000
euros sa fonction trouver le meilleur
compromis entre stabilité et vitesse
[Musique]
laguiole doit être stable et rapide sont
ultra des profils et pourfendre la mer
la coque et alliés pour la vitesse
mais attention l'embarcation doit être
stable pour éviter des avaries à pleine
vitesse
laguiole pu atteindre les 16 go soit 30
km
[Musique]
[Rires]
qui va gagner cette édition
après si tu ne te demande pas ça ne doit
pas se demander vous avez mal posé la
question qui va entre un deuxième
sérieusement ses més à l'agglo toujours
à la baguette normal nous sommes pas
loin de sa tête yahoo intel pour voir
l'ex mérine à l'arrivée côtoie le tour
il avait déjà gagné notre société
je n'ai pas bien suivi mais quoi qu'il
en est quelle que soit la position pour
moi c'est aux ex j'aimerais dire à tania
chaussures de tenir le coup c'est bien
même les derniers bien encourager les
derniers aussi parce qu'il faut aussi
partie de la course s'est passée par une
des soeurs bien faire c'est la machine à
gagner
on va pas dire que c'est déjà gagné mais
bon le faire des gens tête il faut que
je conserve sa première place et voilà
est ce que quand même une chose que fr
vraiment perdre tout non non il va faire
ne va pas perdre de vue et faire de même
à tel point biais au cnra il y en a qui
disent que lorraine peut revenir très
fort non des vues à faire
peut-on encore faire des pronostics
peut-on encore rêver pour certaines yole
wallon le retour et il a définitivement
joué c'est la question à poser à notre
spécialiste et jean trudeau notre
docteur yelles va nous dire ce qui a
fait la différence aujourd'hui sur l'eau
ce qui attend les coursiers demain et si
oui ou non le vainqueur est déjà connu
[Musique]
du jamais vu du jamais vu de l'intox sur
la plage de l'intox ou ne soient les
voir brasserie lorraine fait un choix de
voiles mérite mais savoir brasse qu'ils
enlèvent mairie nous a encore il n'a pas
le temps pour finalement ils partent
parce qu'il part avec une voile de plus
de 60 mètres carrés mairie n'ait été
couillonner est toxique et il garde sa
plus petite voile après on part en
vacances a du bon les mapipi vont soit
montré aujourd'hui mais il n'a qu'une
chose à faire c'est de rester devant
l'autre maillot qu'ils contrôlent
brasserie lorraine c'est sarah énergies
nouvelles et autres sur la plage changer
de voile mais il se dit est-ce que je
suis il va pas changer de voile et plus
on tombe sur une course normale qu'on
aurait vu ya des années auparavant un
combat des chefs
l'ufr jean-florent rosette/orange combat
des chefs combat des chefs jusqu'à
l'arrivée à tour de france rendent
arrivait avec de petites rafales
habituel de petites et fidélité du vent
sous le fort saint louis
demain je le dis tous les jours mais je
le répète ou la dernière fois demain
mais ce sera terrible parce que demain
tout le monde les gars t'as vu on est
dans la baie de fort de france on ne
sort pas de la baie on est dans la baie
ont fait des empannages ont-ils des bof
ce sera compliqué parce que les derniers
hommes vont rencontrer les premiers au
classement général
et puis tout le monde voudra aller à la
victoire d'étape sauf l'ufr chancelant
il ne va pas à la victoire d'étape
parce qu'il va à la victoire finale il a
plus d'une demi-heure sur le 2ème
brasserie lorraine tsar énergies
nouvelles qui en plus ils sont un petit
peu at et au moral alors je consulte mon
petit doigt je conseille la boule je ne
sais pas demain tout le monde voudra
gagner sauf marine mais meriem
vraisemblablement vraisemblablement
jeudi avec beaucoup de points de
suspension remportera sur 34e tour de la
martinique d'ailleurs
[Musique]
demain c'est la huitième étape
elle se déroulera dans la baie des
flamands classé parmi les plus belles
bêtes le monde sait bien qu est ce qui
nous attend pour cette ultime étape
métal et william ont williams ce sera la
dernière ça passe tellement vite on
s'est bien amusé un et on continue
encore et on va en profiter jusqu'au
bout
voici le profil de l'étape de demain
départ et arrivée à fort-de-france 8e et
dernière étape fort-de-france
fort-de-france départ à 10 heures de la
place de la française direction la
marque au numéro un située à la pointe
du bout retrouver à la marque numéro
deux devant la plage de la française à
laisser à bâbord une descente vers la
morgue numéro 3 qui se situe à la pointe
des laisser à bâbord un empannage
remonté il a les yeux les derniers
hommes vont certainement croiser les
premières il y aura quand même de la
gestion à faire dans la flotte
ensuite direction de tirer des bords
vers la marque numéro 4 qui se situe à
part au couvent et on redescend à cette
marque est la marque numéro un qu'on
laisse sur tribord un empannage délicat
une traversée de la baie à toute vitesse
pour aller rejoindre cette man que nous
leur ou trois qui se situe du côté de la
pointe des
la contourner la laisser sur tribord
passé en toile à bouilly et la terre
tirer quelques bords qui nous permette
d'aller couper la ligne d'arrivée
matérialisée par deux bouée située
devant la plage de la française et voilà
qu'à première votre rendez vous
quotidien consacré à la 34ème était sur
du tour de la martinique des yoles
rondes c'est terminé pour aujourd'hui on
vous attend nombreux demain à l'arrivée
ce sera le final un final de toute
beauté dans la baie des flamands
le départ et l'arrivée se passeront ici
sur la plage de la française ça va être
magnifique rejoignez-nous aussi sur
martinique première à 20h et sur france
ô à 7h35
merci à la ligue d'aviron de martinique
de nous avoir permis à nous aussi de
glisser sur l'eau et claude on est parti
à l'ego
super initiation
belle dans l'eau
[Musique]
ça va
mais non
[Musique]
m